[Music]
welcome to off the record where we talk
about whatever we want what's up mike's
back hey
dude you just opened up a new gym huh
yeah middle of covet dude i just said
good call [ __ ] it let's roll how's that
uh
okay has anyone ever told you that you
look like my buddy julian solomida
is he a spanish cat you do look like him
it's bothering me all day i get it
finally i get a lot got it i could put
whip out like 10 that people say i look
like you look like this young dude
that's uh jenna marbles yeah
dude yeah you don't look like young
daniel at all really everyone says
oh i can see that i see that yeah
everyone says
handsome wow very handsome very regular
i remember what you saw i only just saw
young de niro in the irishman so i think
it's kind of [ __ ] anyway
it was all like if i covered his face up
with like lotion or something cg one you
gotta see the godfather that's young de
niro yeah what's the other one uh
he was scammy i don't think he's that
good looking i actually can't take it as
an example
yeah he's not good looking he's kind of
looks beat up what else do you what else
do you get johnny manziel a lot oh i can
see that for sure are you italian yeah
i'm italian argentina all the
argentinian cats like lionel messi and i
don't know if you know
so you do say cats i do say cats no i
wasn't saying it because i knew you
loved jazz i just said cats i knew it i
don't know
all right steve are you a big jazz guy i
love jack
actually uh coal train yeah big time
um i'm sorry i cut you off on your gym
no oh yeah yeah uh it's actually better
i don't know i don't know what eggs
that's crazy because like during covert
a lot of gyms were shutting down
and you guys decided to open one during
copenhagen so we planned it we were
planning it i guess why'd you plan it
like that fall fall of uh
fall of 2019 we started the plan also he
didn't know about the kovitz stuff yeah
so imagine he didn't know get the lease
going and then covet hit and then we
just stopped all conversation of
anything for like
five weeks did you have to you didn't
get the lease yet no we didn't sign
anything but we started the
communication for it and then uh
two weeks to stop the spread
so we so a great line so we went right
back in and started talking about the
lease again
and then we're like well
we need to do a lot of like refurb on
the building anyways so let's do this
and we're going to need three or four
months to refurb this spot
the building was pretty beat up
we really only chose the building based
on our past
my first podcast started in this exact
building my powerlifting career kind of
started in this past building uh any
meatheads out there that jim super
training kind of became popular out of
this gym in like two thousand
it's a powerlifting team gym company so
there was already an existing gym there
so there was a gym in there oh um and
then they were going out of business
you're like this is a good idea i'm
gonna do a gym here as well so uh
something tells me i knew the gym owners
uh i knew the gym owners i was a coach
there back in the day uh and all the
members were hitting me up um i don't
like to talk uh uh poorly on people but
it wasn't managed the best yeah so it
wasn't like a location deal you know so
super trainers was poorly managed no
that's super training not super training
it was a different gym it was a
different gym it was a different gym it
was a different gym that was man is
there training at least you decided to
just take it over buy it off of them uh
no it was totally empty oh they were
already vacated they were gone they were
going earlier
yeah yeah they were booted is there like
a weirdness behind doing that no i don't
think so
did they leave equipment nothing oh yeah
uh rats
okay [ __ ] tons of rats
were they buff
we literally the walls kind of looked
like y'all's walls the walls were kind
of jacked up and there was rats living
in there live and rats mummified in the
insulation
and so we ripped the whole room down i
redid it by hand like so between super
training and your gym there it hasn't
been occupied so super training uh
rented just a space from it yeah they
never like owned the building around the
gym oh okay they just leased a corner of
it it was another joke what super
training left oh it was another gym so
super training leads to gym at least a
space from a gym
yeah so the other gym was there the
whole time i see yeah so rats are very
respectful when they're they're they're
kind die i just i just asked them there
were some true gym rats
yeah
uh yeah so that we just did uh refurb
for like three months wow
it was cool and then what and then like
and then we were we owe the lease now
right like you're you've got to pay
every single month but you have no
numbers she you know you negotiate at
least a little bit like hey bro there's
going on can we get a couple months and
then can we do like a pyramid scheme to
uh or a pyramid uh uh
pyramid uh pyramid like payment so
payment got more expensive as the lease
goes on they were cool with that yeah
they understood it wow they don't have
any other tenants they're like yeah yeah
like we're literally [ __ ]
by the balls it was dead dead middle of
when every business is closing and
freaking out in small business what's
the rule right now are they allowed to
work out in there yeah i think no
capacity masks on i think is the current
rule wow yeah cool yeah everything's
gonna still back and forth i try to not
listen to the news because too negative
but a lot of places are open like
outside of california for uh gyms or
especially um i know in the uk well
they're fully open now but during the
height of kovit they found out that
like
people that went to the gym and they
they like worked out
they don't get as [ __ ] up sure none of
it made sense yeah right and we all know
that like in the beginning like what
shut down and what didn't shut down
why yeah dude we were essential workers
that was what i loved about it
we got classified as essential workers
because podcasts and entertainment or
whatever news yeah we covered news
topics yeah that's wild but all that's
it's why yeah and alcohol uh liquor
stores oh yeah they're essential the
best bevmo
they're they're essential you can tell
they're alcohol who pays what lobbyists
kick the most ass
like incredible entertainment
and alcohol yep well you know all the
california podcasts nobody shut down at
all because rippers too right like all
the strip joints were open no yeah they
were open they were open that was like
one of the things where like the
conservatives got the most pissed about
because churches were shut down but
strippers were essential i'd be pissed
about that too
i
shut down the strip club and then we're
gonna have american revolution
that's true that's one of the real
essentials that's exactly it they know
not to not to [ __ ] with us too hard
that's why we have guns bro that's right
i mean don't step on me bro
is everything up and running now and
it's good yeah we're moving yeah
everything's good yeah we started like
an apparel company with it which uh you
know obviously did fine because online
stuff and online sales did you have any
inspiration for that are you just
clothing yeah you just thought yeah this
is what everyone does i'm a low-key
hipster
um and so i've been into like streetwear
since like 2005. oh so nobody like
inspired you to do your own apparel
company with your gym like that was just
no
seems like a weird idea honestly
everyone does no i told this story i
told this story everyone does yeah i
told this story literally yesterday uh
to our buddy dean who owns caffeine
kilos which is a very big name yeah
fitness and so like the the the youtube
fitness journey because i'm a hipster it
used to be like get 50 000 subs start an
apparel company get 100 000 subs open a
gym and like i'm going through that in
like 2012 2013 14. i'm like attack it's
kind of happy well i'm like i'm not
doing that like [ __ ] them i'm not doing
the right and you're opening the gym
first and then you're opening up them
well now it's like 10 years later and
i'm like
look what i'm doing every day he thinks
he reinvented the wheel i was like red
robin they have [ __ ] merch so it's
all good right yeah but like everybody
right ogus was running guzman was
running like everyone did the same thing
i was like chili's has merch yeah yeah
great dude good morning i brought this
up too i saw a twitch streamer doing an
ad and he's doing a hot pocket ad which
is kind of like gamer or whatever gamer
fuel but when he's talking about it he's
selling hot pocket merch no
the main ad was hot pocket merch not
even a hot pocket he's talking about
like the hoodie he had on hot
2021 is the year of the merch dude dude
they should get hot pocket koozies
[Music]
dude that's genius yeah over the hot
pocket right like like what like what
are the uh what are like the sleeves no
like a hand thing you do to the oven
like an oven mitt
hell yeah because when you buy it you
need a mouth one too hot pocket merch
dude that's actually kind of sick that's
cool i'd golf in that yeah that's so
crazy what is it what is it like a
dessert is it hot pockets like small
little hot pockets with a little logo
too yeah
i haven't had a hot pocket i like how
they i don't know how i'm [ __ ]
there's some foods that are so good you
just don't eat anymore that's very true
like bagel bites yeah bagel bites will
change your life i remember last time i
had a chicken bacon you guys you see
chicken breasts
yeah
pizza
right
out of the hot pockets though i forgot
what anything else was aside from the
pizza one that's the best one
broccoli cheddar i you know everyone
likes to hate broccoli and cheddar and
the ham and cheese one come on i
remember having cheese yeah yeah
but didn't they have like a ton of
different flavors yeah i'm sure they're
pillows sick too the pillow's sick dude
that's a sick pillow hot pockets that
gotta get
dude that's smart that they went all the
way to the game that's smart it's just
like that the game though no real gamers
just like that that dude he's getting
wrecked bro he's kd is terrible
microwave master get out of here dude
that's sick
no the hat is actually sick too yeah
imagine you're [ __ ] heating up hot
pockets but you got to put your apron on
first before you put it in the microwave
convince your friend to be the the hot
pockets guy it's like while you roll
your game it's like hey do you use the
microwave match we both know you you
know right you throw it somewhere you
broke my [ __ ] hot pockets
of lazy food you have to do all this
prep for yourself you gotta put in the
sleeve like put on the hot pockets
t-shirt
we'll be ready in an hour hang on fellas
i'm looking up hot pockets flavors [ __ ]
it like the convenience yeah the
convenience is what was so delicious the
other thing is like uh uh like microwave
dinners oh we were like broke growing up
but we weren't like rich sizes
convenient yeah but microwave dinners
are expansive really i thought they're
like 99 cents if you get the small ones
the lean cuisines are expensive today's
video is brought to you by babel it's
the number one selling language learning
app and you know what's awesome about
babel so lately i went to this foreign
country called the united kingdom you
might have heard of it i don't know it's
a small island yeah but they speak the
language of english and i was like oh
there's a language barrier there i know
i was like what am i gonna do i need to
i don't know their language like i never
traveled to a foreign country before i
have to brush up on my english skills
yeah so thankfully babel has this option
where you can learn english in 14 other
languages there's there's a lot of
languages but i chose english because
when i was there they spoke so weird i
didn't understand what they were saying
english
yeah they don't even know how to speak
english in english they don't know how
to speak american no so i had to get on
babble and get a translator to get me to
understand how to say things correctly
so they can understand real english yeah
i saw like
c-o-l-o-u-r yeah what kind of [ __ ]
is that kollur and then i found out
they're just trying to describe like the
different colors of things
i wanted you to say color instead of
saying kalur
and i'm glad we had babble to figure it
out you know they call trash
they call them bins
bins bins see that's why you can learn
english in many different ways and
what's dope about babel is all the
lessons are in short 15 minute formats
so you can learn it on the go when
you're going jogging in the airport
taking a bagel krappa that's what they
call it at the uk
and they have instead of using ai
technology to teach you they have
hundreds of language experts so you're
learning it in a very practical way and
they help you sound like a native
speaker mm-hmm cheerio terry yos and
they're not talking about the cereal
either and right now there's a special
deal if you get three months of babel
you get another three months for free so
that's getting six months for the price
of three just go to babel.com that's
b-a-b-b-e-l.com and use the code off the
record that's babble.com off the record
to get three months for free when you
get your first three months the hungry
man's those were so good you guys
remember those the hungry man's like a
little [ __ ] brownie up top yeah yeah it
was good though sometimes and the
consistency was good too it was like the
edges were were crispy and then the
inside was gooey i thought it was rich
people food the hungry man no just the
frozen really yeah
you're for asians yeah i'm like how come
how come all my friends get to eat that
i see that in the commercials my mom but
that's rich people yeah our parents
didn't let us eat that growing up
anything branded is like rich people
would you eat [ __ ] i don't know
chinese broccoli and rice something i
don't know that seems more expensive not
the way asians do it have you seen the
way asians do leftovers huh so you'll
like you can get so you get groceries
for the week right and with the same
produce you can make like five different
dishes and then you you make food and
whatever the dish isn't uh
like completed that becomes like a side
dish for tomorrow and then it kind of
like the way that you arrange it like
like 20 bucks will last you groceries
for like if you don't meal you don't
meal prep and do leftovers all week
you just like layer your leftovers kind
of yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah and you just kind of take the
dishes this big and then on friday it's
like on a small plate what's around here
imagine thinking this is rich people
food [ __ ] bank how much is it banquet
banquet that's the one with the
salisbury state what's the price a
dollar 25 dude you get you get nuggets
and a steak good notes you get a steak
and cheese that is cheaper than like a
school you got ripped off dude
that stuff all the time that's dope a
dollar my mom's so dumb dude she didn't
even check we never knew the price of
that [ __ ] we were just told it was my
mom would tell me like you can't eat
that [ __ ] it's bad for you but then we'd
be eating indomie honestly
i mean bad for you 100 natural chicken
breasts bro yeah
you don't know anything
do you guys have a favorite like uh tv
dinner brad probably something like that
or a hungry hunger man or whatever
hungry man because you get like you get
like it look like a chicken breast but
it's a chicken nugget yeah so it's like
this big chicken nugget i'm like [ __ ]
yeah
my favorite college food was when like
uh when you go to the canned section and
sometimes i have crazy deals where it's
like 10 cans of chili for like a buck so
it's like 10 cents each yeah and you
just make rice and you put that over and
you get a runny egg and you put a little
soy sauce on it just yeah that's pretty
good they're like spaghettios
oh yeah [ __ ] yeah should i eat that
right now with the meatballs even okay
you guys might hate on me a little bit
but the chef boyardee lasagna one i was
like that shit's working
lasagna boyardee ravioli too oh the one
that you could microwave and it's all
stuffed
let's do it let's eat canned lunch
even like uh
it's a little more expensive i guess but
probably not much just the frozen
lasagnas like a coffee oh yeah
it's so good we have those at like
school events i love popping chicken pot
pies from home chicken pot pies dude
those monterey [ __ ] burritos those
little yeah yeah the microwave it's good
or like the 711 uh green burritos i
don't even know what makes it green the
tina's bro is it called the tina's no no
the seven lemons it's the same idea but
the tinas are like the
the same one but it's like the red red
chili one and it's like shitty really
shitty stuff but it was good really good
yeah i feel like 7-eleven is kind of a
socal thing we have them but like never
win
really where do you go where you going
[ __ ] since i know but we don't go we
have them i go all the time
you don't need a slurpee or a water is
there an equivalent for norcal or you
guys have ampm yeah yeah but it's not as
common yeah we go to am pm probably well
npm is there because you're getting gas
and it's a little cleaner you can't get
us you can't get a slurpee no they have
like icy things yeah this is good though
the same [ __ ]
is good dude don't hate on it we'll go
to 7-eleven but it's not like a thing
but when i'm down here we go try to turn
it off
you're not better than ice you do don't
don't do that [ __ ] does am pm have
a hot dog just rolling yeah they got all
that the taquitos
oh yeah
they got burgers that have been there so
long it would make you proud all right
it might be cool all right man you can
feed them i'll give it a family at
7-eleven though especially when they
started coming out with the whole pizzas
it's a whole pizza for three bucks
you've been the buckies no
buckies
oh buckies we don't have that here no
it's only texas oh there might be one in
vegas if there is we're going what's
bucky's it's like
uh i don't even know imagine like
kirkland brand me 711 meets like
disneyland in a gas station so it's like
troubles then there's the vegas mint
it's like the biggest gas station market
and it's like good like they have like
their own peanuts and like 30 flavors i
heard they have their own brisket too
like no a good ass brisket like straight
fresh sandwiches a deli a bakery
pastrami and [ __ ] dude you know my
friend did one of those like mukbangs
out of bookies
he got like a million something views
just going to buckies they're amazing
they're just like their drink section is
as big as a 7-eleven just their drinks
go to bucky's dude they're sick but
don't they have like 20 gas stations too
where you can just fill up it's [ __ ]
cause they're only between cities so i
think it's like a trucker spot uh uh but
then they have a whole section where
you're buying like cowboy hats and
little [ __ ] bucky dolls and [ __ ]
march march baby the merch is typhoon
truck stops look legit though cause the
california truck stop looks like you get
a blow job from a two dollar hooker yeah
i ain't going to though no those are
legit though you can
just
that is real yeah that's real [ __ ] have
you seen like at a truck stop when they
have those entertainment rooms they have
a chill area they have a yeah there's
like an area where truckers can chill on
like lazy boy chairs and watch movies
they took a shower in one of them yeah
you take showers and there's like a
full-on rest area it was nice yeah you
just put quarters in and then if you run
out of quarters and the water just gets
cold
do you have to keep you have to like
hold quarters while you're [ __ ]
rubbing it
you put like maybe like four at a time
and then they'll like you'll start going
like oh wait it's getting kind of cold
you gotta put like more quarters
i recently did that at a camp site and
then it's like they run the shower for
like four minutes or something and you
have to keep adding it
in the middle of me soaping that [ __ ]
shut off and i was like [ __ ]
and i had to run out grab quarters again
and put it back in with soap all over me
where are the nice truck stops all the
ones i know are like norcal to like
washington and they're all the sketchy
ones you feel like you're gonna get
stabbed everyone's a sketchy there's
something they said he got a lazy boy no
but these are the exceptions yeah i need
to find the ones with the black bear
diners built into it black bear is kind
of underrated dude i kind of like being
a black bear
yeah i love a diner i love dying
burnt coffee [ __ ] huge pancakes
that's the best yeah i want i want that
coffee all the time i want to be able to
get that coffee at home but i can't i
have to go to a diner and get that i
could eat diner food every [ __ ] day
a lot of variations yeah especially
breakfast we need some lady name luis
serving you and she's super nice for no
reason smells like cigarettes i love her
i love those people man just call her
auntie on the way out get a club
sandwich and a [ __ ] diner for no
reason i like that too i like that too i
put a little bit of tabasco on it i put
a lot of it at tabasco
you soak you'd like use it as a french
dip i do french chips
i love vinegar i love it that's one
thing i wish we had more of in la is
like a legit diner or like all that
stuff is dying out now it's all like
norms is the best we got where is there
even a norms around here
not many do you have like a mom-and-pop
one it's hard because no they're all
turning into hipster spots yeah yeah our
hipster areas have talking arugula in
the sandwich and [ __ ] and it's like come
on man just give me iceberg lettuce dude
what's the one in uh downtown that's
super famous and they never closed the i
know what i'm about and the sourdough
bread
no no no the one you lived next to yeah
yeah that was good
it's like near staples oh okay i don't
know that one it's kind of touristy but
it's good it's been open since 1950 or
whatever and it's never closed mel's is
the one though too it melts is really
good yeah yeah no it's uh how places are
good i like that they closed i drove by
it i'm like oh in there
they finally closed no
clothes for good or just because of
covet i don't know i'm like man that's
it was like crammed in there though like
you you can't but you can imagine like
oh cool like mobsters used to dying in
here
because it looked like it felt like old
l.a jerry's deli is pretty good too take
me to the diners the difference is is so
much when the servers or the cert the
people that work there are not working
there to act or something like that's
just where they work yeah that's where
it is that's how they that's how they
are it's like pride of their like what
they do yeah it's like love being a
server at that diner they've been there
for like 20 years i feel like that's
just way easier in the midwest or
something because you can't live in la
and work at a diner you can't afford it
but in the midwest you could probably
you know at least have a nice rent yeah
and kind of afford it so you care yeah
you
you're okay caring or here it's just a
stress and hate your job and [ __ ] yeah
but it does make them all hotter when
they're trying to be
actors true
true much hotter i agree
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you